Ucrania intenta alegrar una de sus
navidades más oscuras
el mismo día que se cumplen diez meses
desde que inició la invasión rusa los
ucranianos quieren llevar una Navidad
convencional los ataques de los últimos
meses a la red vital dejan al menos el
50% de la población sin electricidad sin
embargo en el árbol fue iluminado para
encender la esperanza
los rusos intentan robarle la vida
normal a nuestros ciudadanos pero no les
daremos la oportunidad de robar las
fiestas más importantes el nuevo año y
Navidad de nuestros hijos es por eso que
decidimos tener el árbol de navidad en
una de nuestras plazas más grandes la
plaza sofisca
Ucrania se rige bajo el calendario
juliano que celebra la Navidad el 7 de
enero pero este año gran parte de la
población renunció a conmemorar la fecha
según el calendario ortodoxo ruso en
nikolife se instaló un árbol de Navidad
hecho con redes de camuflaje en harquive
las estaciones del metro fueron
decoradas y en kiev el artista suizo
Jerry hopster realizó una iluminación
especial en el Museo histórico de
Ucrania
se suma a nuestro estado de ánimo
festivo en un momento tan difícil el
árbol de navidad sigue siendo uno de los
atributos de la celebración de Navidad
[Música]
exactamente tres semanas mi familia y
mis amigos se quedaron allí me preocupo
por ellos todo el tiempo
luego de las conmemoraciones los
ucranianos seguirán defendiendo su país
y buscando refugios seguros